the nation's largest pediatrician
society is calling for new action to
examine the safety of thousands of food
additives and food packaging materials
the American Academy of Pediatrics says
many of the more than 10,000 FDA
approved chemicals added to food and its
packaging have not been thoroughly
tested and they may affect children's
immunity growth and behavior our dr.
Tara
Narula is here doctor good morning I
think this morning got an important
story it's such an important warning
first what are the chemicals that we're
talking about because they're specific
chemicals well I want to agree with what
you said this is a huge statement by the
nation's pediatrician saying look our
food safety system is failing to protect
the health of our children and this
comes after two decades of scientific
concern that's been raised about
additives causing disease and disability
so we're talking about direct additives
which are artificial colorings
flavorings chemicals like nitrates and
nitrites as well as indirect additives
these are substances and the materials
that come in contact with our food so
plastics adhesives containers tubing in
the manufacturing processes and explain
why there's special concern for toddlers
it's not Jinyoung Children's not just
when they're eating them - it can also
be the mother eating them when when
she's pregnant right well children can
receive a relatively higher
concentration based on the amount
they're getting for their body weight
number one number two their metabolic
system their detoxification systems are
still developing and number three they
have key organ systems that are still
maturing and when you look at the
potential effects it's widespread it's
endocrine disruption so hormone is
hormone disruption sex hormones thyroid
hormones it can lead to potential for
obesity cardio toxicity carcinogenesis
immunosuppression so lots and lots of
potential worrisome effects even
behavioral effects that on the road this
seems like a vast array of foods here's
what the FDA says says it's reviewing
the findings in the report and the FDA
says if new information suggests that a
substance already in use may be unsafe
the FDA can conduct further studies to
review whether the use can still be
considered safe but what kind of a
review it sounds like we're talking
about it yeah I asked Amelia
so pediatricians are saying we need a
big kind of overhaul of the system we
need better oversight and regulate
we need the FTA to have more authority
to go back and review chemicals that are
already out there that may have been
reviewed years ago with older techniques
we also need updated labeling we need to
look at long term behavioral effects
which we really don't study cumulative
effects of multiple chemicals and really
better toxicity testing but one of the
biggest issues is that a lot of these
additives are getting into the market
based on being considered generally
recognized as safe this is the heading
they're falling under this was put out
there back in the 1950s as a way to kind
of get things like oil and vinegar on
the market most importantly for parents
that really quick things they should do
consume fresh frozen fruits and
vegetables what else avoid processed
meat exactly so avoid microwaving food
and beverages and plastic containers
don't put those plastics in the
dishwasher peel fruits and vegetables if
you're not washing them look at the
bottom of your plastics to look for
codes three six or seven and avoid those
unless it says green ware or right you
should not be using bottles that have
three six or seven on the bottom oh
that's right and on the bottom meeting
the recycling exactly respectively code
okay dr. taryn rule the tanks